Raymond, my man, thank you so much uh
for taking time out of your incredibly
busy schedule of lecturing all over the
country, all over the world uh to come
on the show and join us uh to discuss uh
some incredible uh uh wisdom and
knowledge that you've acred over your
adult life as to the power of of
Christendom and and what it means uh for
societies. Uh and I just can't thank you
enough for joining us.
It's my pleasure, David. I'm very happy
to be with you. Thank you.
Great. Um I you know I just before we
get started I just wanted to give the
audience man you know where I first
discovered Raymond was uh during my time
uh right after working for the CIA uh
when Libya went down. Um, part of the
spin that came out of that was uh the
the government and powers in particular
Hillary Clinton had suggested that all
of this took place as a result of these
videos online that had sparked this
outrage. Uh, and and after further
digging in, we realized that all of that
was just a fabricated lie. These were
pre-planned attacks. uh if you're paying
attention to Sarah Adams who's on Shawn
Ryan all the time, my best friend, uh or
or better yet, you've you've listened or
or paid attention to Raymond for as long
as I have, you realize that that's not
the case. And I and I what I I just want
to say thank you for the work you did to
debunk that and to prove uh what my
buddies were saying, not only in their
book 13 hours, but what they've
testified to that this was pre-plane, it
was staged, and it was coming. And so
that that really made a huge impact on
me and and I appreciate your stance to
bring out the truth in that particular
incident too. Yeah, my pleasure. That's
uh such a long time ago. But I do
distinctly recall, you know, there was
one of the advantages of being bilingual
and knowing Arabic and watching Arabic
media, reading Arabic uh literature is
uh you actually get the unvarnished
truth while you're hearing a completely
different spin in English in America.
And I was hearing way before that movie
supposedly came out to upset Muslims
that they were planning on this uh major
protest. And then of course, as you say,
I recall the Obama administration,
Hillary Clinton trying to pin it on some
no-name movie maker who apparently upset
Muslims by, you know, some nonsense. So,
yeah, unfortunately, there's a lot of
that going on. All right, Raymond. So
the the thing I'd love to have you do is
to provide some context for folks out
there because I think what's taken place
in a lot of the history books and the
way history is taught is is that somehow
these crusades kind of launched out of
these Christian crusades launched out of
nowhere to go back and conquer uh the
holy land where where the opposite is
actually true. There had been hundreds
of years of of jihad waged against
Christianom, not only in the ancient
cities of of where Christianity origin,
but making its way all the way up into
Europe. So, would you provide a little
context as to the magnitude and the the
savagery that was involved in those
initiatives?
Absolutely, David. And you you know, you
you hit on the most important point when
it comes to the Crusades, which is that
they're always presented nowadays in a
vacuum. In other words, and I'll give
you a perfect example. I' I've almost
memorized this quote from a professor
from a Georgetown professor where I
actually went before over 20 years ago.
Um, his name is John Espazito and he's
supposed to be an expert on Islamic
history, etc., etc., very many books.
He's a consultant for, you know,
intelligence departments, FBI, CIA,
military, Pentagon. And in one of his
books, I'm I'm I'm slightly paraphrasing
it, but it's almost verbatim. He says
something like, "Five centuries of
peaceful coexistence elapsed between
Christians and Muslims before an
imperial papal power play led to
centuries of so-called uh holy wars that
have left an enduring legacy of mistrust
and resentment from Muslims to
Christians." Okay, so what he's saying
is that right before the first crusade
was called in 1095, you had nothing but
pure peace between Muslims and
Christians. Okay. So, obviously if you
believe that and as you can see that's
what they pedal um you're going to the
to you the crusades the first crusade at
least uh is going to come off as um a
completely unwarranted offensive
campaign against peaceful Muslims. All
right. So what really happened? Okay.
Now let's go back. He mentioned the five
centuries which essentially he's going
way back to the time of Muhammad was
born. But basically uh by the time
Muhammad dies and the Arabian peninsula
is uh consolidated under Islamic rule
and the first and second and third
Khalifs etc you have what's known in
history as the great Arab conquests
where they spread out um and conquer.
Now most people again because this is
part of the spin don't realize that the
lands that they conquer the lands that
we know today in North Africa and the
Middle East, Syria, Lebanon, Israel, uh
Jordan, Iraq and of course Egypt and
Libya and Algeria, Tunisia, Morocco, all
of that was not just Christian, it was
more Christian than Europe. That was
really the heart of a Christian world at
the dawn of Islam in the 7th century at
the time of these Arab conquests that
I'm referring to.
And um if you look at the sources which
I've done uh the primary sources from
both sides, Muslims and Christians that
the contemporary earliest sources, it
was essentially just mass destruction
and from the Muslim side is definitely
described as a jihad. Okay, so they're
conquering the infidel according to the
principles that we know. You give the
non-Muslim three choices, convert or
become a, you know, you pay tribute and
you're the mei and you're a secondass
citizen, etc. Or you fight to the death.
Okay. So that's how it's uh definitely
presented in the Islamic sources and in
the Christian sources it's just seen as
mass destruction and chaos and
enslavement, massacres, destruction,
ritual destruction of churches. And
that's how you know actually even from
the Christian side because they still
didn't know, this is very early who
these Muslims are and what they want.
But uh it comes out in the sources that
there's definitely an ideological
component because they were very much
attacking crosses and churches and going
out of their way to desecrate them.
uh Sophrinus the bishop of Jerusalem who
was actually living at the time around
637 actually says all this uh so long
story short one from a century after
Muhammad's death the traditional date
being 632 AD and now reached 732 and
excuse me Islam has now conquered all of
North Africa those countries I mentioned
Egypt to Morocco and all of the Middle
East it was known as greater Syria
greater Syria essentially encompassed
those other countries, Lebanon and
Israel, etc. And um now they're and
they've conquered Spain, which we'll get
into uh in the year 7-eleven. And now in
732, they're in the middle of France
where you have the famous battle of Tow.
Yeah. Or the battle of Guatier. And uh
Charles Martell and it's it's known as
what you know, an epic great victory. I
have a whole chapter about it in uh one
of my books, Sword and Scimitar chapter
3, I think, because it is that pivotal
and that's my favorite one. I love that
book. Thank you. Thank you. And um okay,
so there it is. So in the in you know I
just mentioned that quote from John
Espazito five peaceful coent you know
centuries had elapsed before those evil
crusaders. And just in the first century
3/4 of Christendom the older richer more
sophisticated more important section was
completely destroyed and enexed and
Islamized. So apparently that's that's
part of the five centuries of peaceful
coexistence paradigm. Okay. And we can
get into a lot of details of what
happened, but I'm going to try to fast
forward. Um, you know, in the year 1009,
so I'm already talking about, you know,
we we ended at 7:32 between 7:32 and the
11th century. You have now the all the
Mediterranean nations, uh, or sorry,
islands get conquered. And it's again,
it's the same thing. It's depradations.
You have mass slavery going on, you
know, of the Berbers. The way the
sources talk about it, it sounds like a
mass slave campaign, especially. Um and
then the so 10 109 the reason I brought
that up is again to underscore just what
was happening before the first crusade.
And here you have a fatime khif Shia
khalif people don't they forget that in
Egypt was actually ruled by Shia for a
couple of centuries um or even more
actually. And that even Alazar, it's an
ironic fact, Alazar, this great bastion
of Sunni learning uh the greatest
Islamic Sunni college in uh the entire
world was founded as a Shia school and
people don't realize that I find that
interesting. Anyway, that khalif uh
hakim his name in 1009 according to
Muslim sources destroyed 30,000 churches
in Egypt and Syria, greater Syria, which
once again uh emphasizes and shows you
how Christian those regions were and uh
also gives you an idea of the sorts of
persecution that was going on alongside
the destruction of the churches was
again persecution against Christians as
well as Jews and all sorts of taxations
making them wear like 10 pound crosses.
around their necks and they have to ride
donkeys backwards and all sorts of
humiliating um injunctions and whatnot.
So again, I only this is just these are
I'm just giving you slight examples.
There's many many more of what was
happening that completely flies in the
face of the characterization that there
was nothing but peace between Muslims
and Christians until those pesky
crusaders came along. Okay. And then
okay so let's fast forward some more. Um
then around the middle of the 11th
century of the rise of the Turks,
specifically the Seljic Turks who were
imported originally as slave soldiers
and they essentially take over um the
Abbashad Caliphate and they keep the
Khalif as a figurehead and this goes on
for a long time. But if you look at the
sources um at this time the you know we
know about the Armenian genocide at the
hands of the Turks around the 20th
century and the late 19th century but it
really went on it started a thousand
years earlier because if you look at the
sources and I'm specifically thinking of
Matthew Adessa a contemporary uh he
basically documents how those Turks came
rushing in from the east and entered
Anatolia or Asia Minor which is now
Turkey and where you had a huge Armenian
population and they the records just
talk about the sack and destruction and
massacre of tens of thousands of
Christians and the enslavement of even
more and the ritual desecration and
destruction of churches and crosses. Uh
so just in one city Ani which was the
capital of Armenia at the time this is
maybe I think around 1065
um the Muslim Turks Seljixs it was known
as the city of a thousand1 churches and
they ritually destroyed all 101 churches
they destroyed all all the crucifixes
except for one very large gilded cross
which they sent as a trophy of war to
Baghdad once again underscoring the
ideological component that this wasn't
just war between two groups. groups that
this was literally a jihad against the
infidel.
So this is now going on and then in the
year
1071 uh about 6 years later you have the
famous battle of Manzikert also uh
featured in my book Sword and Sumitar
because it's very decisive battle where
the Turks defeat the Eastern Roman
Empire the Byzantines as they call them
and after that you know all all
resistance collapses in Asia Minor and
the church are running a muck all the
way westward through Asia Minor till
they're essentially right across from
Constantinople. Um and this so this is
the background of the first crusade and
at the same time the Turks were also
because pilgrimage to the holy land had
always gone on and even after the
initial Muslim conquest Jerusalem was
conquered in 637 even at that point
pilgrimages continued and most Muslim
rulers were smart enough to allow it
because they completely taxed and
extorted the visiting Christians from
Europe to come visit the holy sites uh
in Jerusalem and elsewhere. Um and even
then they were attacked and killed by
the populace etc. But during during the
time I'm describing the rise of the
Turks it was extremely horrific. Um they
the abuses that the Turks were
inflicting on European pilgrims and one
of them is actually very well known.
It's around also I think the year 1065
when Anie was being sacked and it's it's
been it's recorded in at least one well
doumented source where you have an
eyewitness talking about how they
actually it was a it was a large German
pilgrimage going to the Holy Land and
among them was a this a very she's
described as a very beautiful but a nun
who was a very chased nun and you know I
think she's an abbus actually and they
took her and ritually gang raped her in
front of everyone until she died. Okay.
And then the chronicler ends it by
saying, "And the Turks did sort these
these sorts of abuses all the time
against our people such as the backdrop
and the impetus and motivation for the
first crusade." So if you listen to what
Pope Urban and you know Peter the hermit
and all the preachers of the first
crusade, this is what they were talking
about. If you read the letters that the
emperor Alexius, Eastern Roman Emperor
sent to the West appealing for aid,
that's what he described. Okay? uh what
I just described and and even more you
know they talk about how they would go
into the churches the Turks and split
open people and tie their intestines to
the you know coal and wick them until
they die they would circumcise boys and
throw the blood in baptismal fonts etc
etc at which point Pope Orin finally
said it you know who's going to address
and avenge and redress these wrongs and
which point the famous line deos vult
came out God wills it and all the all
the Franks and Christians who heard it
committed to the first crusade. So
that's what really was happening leading
to the first crusade even though we are
told and most people think that there
was nothing but peaceful coexistence
amongst Muslims and Christians until
those evil pesky Catholics decided to go
and ruin it all.
Uh it's it's staggering to me, you know,
how easily history is manipulated, but
that's been the case, I mean, forever,
right, to the victor of the spoils and
and and and what what what really I
think for me as as a Christian and and
I'm a relatively new Christian. I got
saved in 2010, you know, on on a trip
right before I went out to Afghanistan.
I was about ready to have my first
child. And I, you know, I'd been
struggling with my faith since I left
the teams and trying cuz I knew that God
was watching out for me. I just didn't
know how to how to accept it and what to
do with it. And so it was this battle
that took place with me because I didn't
understand the history. And and and and
even though I was able to to, you know,
read the New Testament and read the Old
Testament, you know, as a young man, I
didn't know how to decipher that or
where to find it. And so it I think it
really comes down to these, you know,
unique stories of of individuals that
really kind of flip or change um the
ability for people to become emotionally
invested in the past or the history,
their legacy or lineage. And and you
know, I once I got saved, I got deeper
and deeper. I found you in 2012.
uh started following, paying attention
and was like, "Oh my god, you know, this
is what all my buddies during the G-WA,
you know, them with those tattoos like
like Secretary Hegsth and you know, I I
had I don't even know five or six
friends that had the Jerusalem cross
across their whole backs and they and
they would look at me and they'd be
like, "Hey, Rut, man, you need to know
your history if you're going to be a
Christian." I go, "I'm not even sure
what that means. What do you you know?"
And and so what I would love for you to
do and one of the things that I think
one of the places that I've been
inspired was the story of the reconista
in Spain which is you know if you know
hopefully you you'll you can do it a
much you know better description than I
can but it was this small pocket of
Christians that were like hey if we
don't rise up it's over for us we will
be permanently conquered forever and I
just want I you know for you to share
that story and that movement and the
impact that it has because what I want,
you know, young Christian men out there
or even young men who who are who
believe in the western the the the
beauty of of Western culture and its
emergence because it was directly
correlated to Christendom, you know, to
give them something they can lean into.
So, would would you talk about Spain a
little bit for us?
Yeah, absolutely. Um, and all you said I
agree with. You know, there's, and maybe
we'll get into it, but uh, it's really a
concerted effort to uh, divorce
uh, modern-day Christian men from their
rich, robust, muscular heritage and
convince them that if you want to be a
good Christian, you have to be a
doormat. And anything other than that
is, you know, you're you're an evil
hypocrite. Okay? And that's a that's its
own very important topic, uh, which at
some point we can address. But as far as
the reconista in the story that you're
referring to, this is you know I always
say it but you know the famous uh saying
which is history is uh stranger than
fiction. Uh in this case history is way
more dramatic than fiction and the story
will which I'll quickly summarize. This
could be such a blockbuster movie and
they don't even have to exaggerate. They
don't have to you know the script is
written and it's called the historical
records in the chronicles. But
basically, yeah, basically as I was
alluding earlier, in the year 7-Eleven,
the Muslims finally having conquered all
of North Africa and now they're in
Morocco or Moritania, um they now uh
cross the straits and they're in Spain
and they conquer it. And of course,
Spain at this point is a Christian
nation um ruled by the Visiggoth or the
Western Goths who are Christians. And um
they they beat them, they destroy them,
they oust them and they essentially take
over. Um now, oh, you know, think of the
the the peninsula of Spain. If you
split, it looks like a square. If you
split it in four, the northwestern the
the top left and not all of it, but just
a very very small northern portion,
which is very rugged, mountainous, uh
you know, uh in tempmperate weather, not
a great place. Um uh so most Christians
were conquered and they became subjects
of the Muslim invaders as they became
known the Moors and uh but a very very
small pocket actually fled a sort of
resistance group and lived in the
mountains and uh you know depending on
the sources according to the Muslim
sources it was something like 12 you
know Christians one of them who became
their king is Pelagius or Paleo and he's
sort of uh you know he's the founder
essentially of the resistance movement
against uh is the Muslim conquest of the
Spain. So they're holed up literally in
a cave and according to uh al- Makari
who's one of the primary Muslim
historians of this time like I said
they're just a small group and the
Muslims tried to ou them but it was just
too difficult in that terrain and they
said what are 10 or 12 Christians let
them
rot and from that uh and the Christians
themselves pelagious so at one point
during the conflict before they said let
them rot um they had a parlay at the
cave And uh one of the and the man who
parlayed with Pelagius was actually some
bishop who had succumbed to Islamic rule
and was now a you know a dimmni and sort
of you know a henchman for the Muslims.
He went there to try to control him and
say you know don't resist join us and um
Pelagius resisted and said and he
basically likened their little cave to
the mustard seed in the in the parable
of Christ which grows into a great
kingdom. Okay. And he said from this
tiny mustard seed which you know you're
mocking we're going to come back and
they did century after century. So from
that small seed you had very a very few
small in the northwestern quadrants
again Christian kingdoms developed and
um you know they and and the whole thing
between them was war with the Muslims
and this is the reconqu the reconista
and it starts slowly and slowly they
start moving southward and southward but
even before that you know they were
still in the cave and whatnot the
Muslims were waging and sending two two
annual campaigns according you know the
Sharia you have to go and devastate and
they would go and devastate and take as
many slaves as they could and kill. So
this is I always called Spain as
something of a microcosm of of the
perennial jihad between Christendom and
Islam. It was all concentrated there.
People often think of the Holy Land and
the Crusades and justifiably so but
really if you look at Spain it just it
was all there in one encapsulated you
know closed off sort of like I said
microcosm. Um so it was a continuous
warfare and it begins the Ricoista there
you know depending on the dates some
actually say the real formal date is in
1085 when Toledo is conquered. Toledo is
essentially right in the heart of Spain
and it was the old Visig Gothic capital.
Um so when it was taken from the Muslims
this was a real watershed moment. Um,
and at any rate, it was the same thing.
They continued waring
constantly. And, you know, you get all
these now savage, wild Berber Islamic
fanatical groups that come from Africa
who are essentially ISIS. They're
actually described as dressed in black
and all you see is their eyes and all
they do is scream, you know, tal or
jihadist slogans essentially. And they
come and they create mountains of heads,
pyramids of Christian heads, and there's
wars. And this goes on, you know. So
7-Eleven is a conquest. Soon thereafter
you have the the mountain Pelagius and
the resistance begins. And basically
this goes on until 1492. So we're
talking over 700 years. All right. Um
this is how long it took Spain to rid
itself of invading Islam and all the
depradations. Cordova, which we hear of
as this great, you know, bastion of
multiculturalism. Again, this is how the
historians like to present it or some of
them anyway was actually a massive slave
emporium uh for the entire Muslim world
because it was a base in Spain in Europe
and they preferred fairs skinned slaves.
So, it was from that base that they
would get northern uh um slaves from
Spain and also from Europe all
throughout Europe. Um so, that was much
of its wealth was the slave trade, you
know. And anyway, and you you fast
forward all the way, like I said, to
1492 and um Ferdinand and Elizabeth, um
Isabella, and you know, that's and even
then that's not the end of it because
essentially Granada, the final bastion
of Islam, their southern tip is captured
and then the Muslims have uprisings and
for centuries they're now pretending to
be Christians and engaging in what's
called tea, but their hearts still with
Islam. and we can get into that. But
anyway, that is the story of uh it's
heroic resistance, self-sacrifice. I I
write about it a lot in both my books um
because it is like you said one of the
most pivotal moments and it it's one of
those things like I said imagine you can
make what a blockbuster movie that would
be of just heroic resistance but they
will never do that because the
resistance is from Christians fighting
Muslims who are conquering their lands
and that's not the those are all topics
that nobody's wants to touch. If it was
the opposite, if it was Christians
terrorizing and killing Muslims, of
course, that would be all over the and
the Muslims could be presented as
heroes, yeah, that would be a major
movie. But such as it is, it won't. Oh
man, I I I completely concur with that.
You know, I I think about, you know, as
a kid and and what were the things that
really were inspiring me and and I can't
imagine if if there had been uh more
movies that really uh talked about that
historically for me, you know, in the
70s growing up, you know, I'm I'm it's
all, you know, the World War II movies,
right? It's a bridge too far. It's uh uh
uh you know, those movies. Um and then
you know it's also the the other
concepts of uh you know American past
our American past of in in in the United
States and the conquest right one of the
things you know what what why do kids
always play you know cowboys and Indians
is because you grew up during those
times and now you're like yeah man we
you know these people these trappers in
particular I just read an article
yesterday about how Scottish uh uh
immigrants and in the you know 1600
hundreds would join forces with Native
Americans and integrate into their
tribes and in in order to you know
understand the the savage west and you
know so there's all this history that
had I been exposed to as a young man
would have driven me I in my opinion
closer to faith because I would have
said all right oh man I you know because
one of the things that I I think I
struggled with after leaving the teams
was all right I I need to I need to, you
know, put that away, you know, I need to
put that that warrior mindset off to the
side so I can, you know, integrate into
society where when you I mean, just the
time you're talking about from what 711
to 1492 and even beyond, you know,
Christians have been fighting for their
place in the world, for their place in
their own lands against a neverending
assault, right? and and and if I had
seen that and if I had seen, you know,
something powerful like that, what that
would have done, it would have, I think,
strengthened my face, therefore
strengthened my co culture and
strengthened my confidence of where I
come from and who I am. Um, so I agree.
Now, there is there is a I think
a a little bit of a gouge out there that
uh Mel Gibson is is making a movie about
the siege at Malta. I'm I'm hoping
that's a true and it's not just internet
nonsense. But maybe that'll crack the
case, right, and and get started for us.
I'd actually like to comment what you
just said. Please. I'd like to elaborate
because you you really made you you
really brought up some very important
points which resonate with me uh when I
was a younger man as well. Uh especially
I always thought like if I want to be a
good Christian, I have to essentially be
a woman. You know, I had to be so
emasculated and anything that I had a
natural proclivity for. You know, I've
always enjoyed medieval warfare and the
image of a knight and warriors from all
cultures. You remember the movie
Excalibur back from the old days? Of
course.
The lady of the lake. Like I must dude
if I dude I don't know how many of off
the time Ray and I come out and I'll go
just be sitting there my kids will be
around and I'll go
on right and they'll be like what the
hell are you saying? I'm like it's it's
the sorcery.
Yeah.
Sorry, you know and but there's this
kind of like thing in in the culture
especially again if you want to be a
western Christian where like that's bad.
you know, you're you're that's that's
evil. You have to be a doormat. That's
the only thing. I've since come to learn
that this is actually all by design. You
know, if you're an enemy of
Christianity, the number one thing that
you're going to want to do is convince
Christians that the religion begins and
ends with turning the other cheek. Okay?
And it doesn't. Is that a component of
Christianity? Of course. But it's very
much balanced with something else. And
that's, you know, the the classic idea
of heresy. The meaning is you take one
aspect of teachings and you ignore the
the rest. And uh so that's really what's
going on. They've they've convinced
Christians, you know, you want to be a
good Christian man, then you're
essentially going to become a woman.
Okay? You have to be totally
emasculated. You have to um you know,
reject any kind of militancy or anything
like that because that's all evil.
That's evil crusaders. And this, by the
way, is why the crusaders are so hated.
They must constantly and always be
demonized because if people really know
what they're all about, they're actually
very attractive and something you are
going to gravitate towards and kind of
want to emulate, okay? Because they are
heroic and they're good and they're
Christian and they're noble and
chivalous, etc., etc. So, that's why I
think for decades, if not centuries,
they've been so attacked and undermined
because people uh who don't like
Christianity. I I I mentioned this
sometimes, but you know, I don't it was
it wasn't the last Super Bowl. I think
it was the one before where this is the
classic example. They had this
commercial and there was no talking. All
it was was images of people washing the
feet of other people. Okay? And it was,
ironically enough, all the people on
their knees washing feet were white,
normal, traditional looking Americans.
and everyone getting their feet washed
where okay people of color a Muslim
wearing a turban a woman in a hijab um
you know a migrant who obviously in the
scene is like they just cross the border
and it ends up by saying something like
um Jesus didn't preach hate he washed
his feet okay so that is the approved
promoted form of Christianity in the
west and and if you follow that and
that's all you do which is you're you're
a doormat and you turn the other cheek
and and by By the way, it's easy to do
all that stuff. So, in a way, it's kind
of a they make a virtual advice the
Christians who actually embrace this
because it's easy not to be
confrontational. It's easy not to stand
up for what's right. It's easy to be a
doormat and let people walk all over
you. So, um but that is the kind of
thing that's being approved. And you can
see why it is so unattractive and why so
many men fall away from Christianity
rightfully so because that is not it.
That's not the truth. the real
Christianity. Yeah, you have tolerance.
You have forgiveness, but you also have
cords of whips and tables being
overturned in righteous indignation and
wrath and that has been completely torn
us under and not part of our Christian
heritage. Um, which the crusaders and
all these preodern heroic Christians
definitely understood. So, I think
that's um you know, you and when you
mentioned what you were saying, it
reminded me too of my my youth and how I
just thought like either I'm a really
bad Christian or I need to like stop
liking these things. Um and this is also
why you find Westerners who convert to
Islam because it it at least it gives it
room to vent for these sorts of
masculine traits. Uh and if you feel
like the only thing, you know,
Christianity all offers is beeping and
acting like a woman and being a doormat.
Yeah. I get it for how that so many men
just can't tolerate that. It's so uh
against their nature. Anyway, that was a
little rant that you sort of provoked in
my mind. I I I'm glad you said it. I you
know what I found fascinating is that
you know you you've got this beautiful
Egyptian descent, right? You you grew up
speaking Arabic and English and and and
so you can read the language. So, it's
not as if, you know, you're you're
interpreting it through uh all those
different uh you know, translations that
either diluted or whatever the message
or protected the message, if you will.
But, you know, I I certainly have I've
have spent my fair share in in in Muslim
lands. uh in particular most of the time
I spent I spent in in Afghanistan and
and you know I worked with a ton of
different interpreters and and from
different sects and different uh you
know backgrounds Shia and Sunni and you
know have innumerable friends that uh
you know have worked with all of them
different in Iraq and all over Africa
you name it and and you know what what
what I always you know extrapolated from
their stance when I would press them cuz
when I was doing that I was going
through this time in my life trying to
figure out what it meant to be a
Christian. Can I be a warrior and a
Christian, too? And it's because I had
no background. I had no understanding of
of the knowledge that you have, the
wisdom that you have from our
background. And so I would hear these
men talk to me in in earnestness because
they they have a tendency any culture
that's been involved in war for as long
as the Afghans have, they they talk in
in in in real terms and and their
perceptions and and terms that are uh uh
imbued with the um the presence of
violence, right? Eye for an eye. And and
so what I remember respecting most about
their stance in their faith was the the
the the the strength that they imbued in
them, the the masculinity that emerged
from their faith. And I had a profound
respect for that. And I think we're
seeing that uh uh you know kind of rise
again. And we're seeing that rise again
in in in areas that had you know
traditionally been predominantly
Christian in nature. And and when you
look at at Western Europe and you look
at, you know, you look at uh Britain and
you look at or England and you look at
uh uh Ireland, man, you you see there's
I think this uh confidence collapse
that's taking place because of the
profound amount of imig immigration
that's happening. When you look at
what's going on in in in Europe and and
to a certain extent in America, you
know, there was that just that recent
thing in New Jersey that they're trying
to implement Sharia law in a particular
magistrate, you know, but you look at in
particular Europe and the place where
these, you know, the the historical
relevance of these these men that fought
back against the tyranny of of jihad,
you know, what is taking place uh for
these young men over there? What is a
way that they can uh reintegrate
themselves as as a predominant voice in
their cultures in order to combat what
seems to be uh a growing uh temperature
of of radicalization.
Yeah, they unfortunately have a long and
hard road against them because they've
gone so far back with what they've done.
And again, you know, the best way to
understand is compare and contrast their
behavior with their ancestors who I
describe in, you know, let's say
defenders of the west who I talk about
European heroes who were the exact
opposite. These were the men that we
were alluding to earlier, the heroes who
actually gave everything they had and
they didn't have to. A lot of these men
were kings and emperors who actually
left everything just to go and fight and
defend the cause of Christendom. And you
know it's what's interesting to me and
I've said this before is whereas Muslims
are walking in perfect continuity with
their ancestors they still have the same
mentality because it's part and parcel
of Islamic teaching which is hostility
for the non-Muslim the infidel the keer
and you know the imperative to conquer
and subjugate etc. And you see this uh
by m from Muslims both in the Muslim
world but even more so in Europe because
wherever you go and you have large
pockets of Muslims you know think think
Sweden think England Germany France you
have problems serious problems okay but
then the west I was we were talking
about the defenders of the west the
Christians their modern descendants are
actually walking in perfect
discontinuity with their ancestors so
instead of fighting tooth and nail and
resisting them they're going out of
their way to bring them in. And I always
say this and it's just it's so
mindboggling when you think of it this
way, but unfortunately too many Western
people, white people if you will, they
think of themselves as sort of, you
know, as because they look at Western
nations and they see that they're still
the majority and they think somehow um
you know, they owe it to everyone else.
But in reality, if you look at the world
population, the white population is
something like 4% of the whole world.
And I just find it amazing that that 4%
is the one that is being obligated to
open its doors to everyone to abnigate
and disavow its heritage and its
religion and its culture and its
civilization to suppress itself. It's
just amazing. You know, have you never
seen such self-suicidal impetus? And
then you compare it to the earlier the
ones we're talking about, the heroes,
their their forefathers. Little wonder
they hate them and they don't want to
talk about the crusaders and they want
to suppress them because they're doing
the exact opposite. Uh whereas the first
guys, the the the heroes were fighting
for the cause of Christian and
Christianity, fighting for their
cultures and their civilization, these
Europeans, at least their leaders are
doing everything possible to destroy
their people. I mean, when you look at I
when I hear stories coming out of
England, the attack on free speech that
you can't even say the truth and and
you're going to get it's just I don't
get how the English people don't realize
they've become slaves. Okay. And it
doesn't matter if they think those
people are elected officials or not.
It's it's one big charade at this point
when they're doing what they're doing.
And it's so obvious. Wow. I saw and I tr
and I put in one of my books. I have a
quote from um some sort of
parliamentarian in Germany. I think in
Munich, Stephanie something. And
basically she gets up and says, "Oh, you
know, I have news for all you
right-wingers who are complaining that,
you know, this city or Germany general
is going to be Muslim majority in
whatever years." And that's what
actually some pew pew pew numbers, pew
results, pew polls say that like 20
something like 2050 Muslims might be
like 50%. And she goes and that's a good
thing. I mean, think about that
mentality and and I just told you you're
4% of the world population and you're
boasting because you're that 4% in its
own homeland is giving up its homeland
even more. It's just it's really a sick
almost diabolical mentality and it's
become so pervasive that people don't
notice it. It's, you know, I always talk
about the boiling frog syndrome. You
know, if you're if you're in that and
you're just boiling and boiling and
boiling, it just you don't even get it
anymore. But this is if you if you can
step out of reality for a m if people
could look at what's happening in the
west and what the west is doing to
itself it's just mindboggling. It's
utterly unprecedented. And uh but as far
as your question you know what what man
you can do that's this is why I say it's
so hard because everything is set
against them. everything um from the way
these uh the models of Christianity are
being demonized constantly to the fact
that you can't even open your mouth
without possibly getting in trouble with
the law. It's uh the system is not going
to work for them. Okay, the bottom line
is doing it the normal way at the voting
poll or the voting booth, it's not going
to work because the whole thing is at
this point rigged. But at the same time,
you know, I was telling you why do they
actually try to emasculate men and
Christians? There's a reason that they
want to con here in the west you know
they want to convince every boy that
he's a little girl and it's not just
perversion which it is but it's also if
you want to rule and govern and dominate
a place you want to do you want to rule
and govern a country run by women and if
I turn every man and make him think he's
a woman essentially and he's just given
up on he doesn't ever resist I'm going
to rule and control that country. So
that's I think been going on for decades
and that's why Western men have been so
emasculated and uh so even at this point
I don't think they could you know get up
and do what they have to do which is
whatever is necessary because of
generations of them being so utterly
emasculated from every corner one from
kindergarten from the media from the
church that they go to uh it's become a
very difficult thing um and you know
it's not very hopeful But such is a
situation and it might have to get worse
before it gets better.
Wow. That's heavy and and and true. All
of it. Everything you said. Um before I
let you go, Raymond, because I know how
busy you are and I again I really
appreciate your time. Is there a
particular person that you a story that
that you can reference or just, you
know, drop that seed, right? be that
sewer for young men that are going to
watch this show or even young women, you
know, that that are fascinated by what
you're saying. But is that there there's
that one person in in in history that if
they dig into and they get going that
that they could get going uh and find
this history and and bring it back to
life uh uh and as almost a um you know a
crusade in their own faith, right? in
their own soul. The battle that's take
being waged in their own soul. Is there
is there a person that you would uh lead
to?
Yeah, actually and it may be because we
already spoke about him, but I'll tell
you why it's even above and beyond that.
But it's Pelagius of Spain of the
Reconista, the man who was in the holdup
region. And the reason I say that is his
situation was not unlike what I just
described. Think about it. His country
had been destroyed and taken over by the
enemy openly. and a lot of his
countrymen succumbed and be and and you
know were willing to live as basically
secondass citizens of Muslims and they
were being abused you know even though
they were paying their tribute it wasn't
they were but he and a very tiny band of
radicals and who would not dain to
submit to the yoke of Islam suffered and
went and lived in a cave just and they
were described like animals who were
just going to die off because they
didn't even have food. Okay. And because
that's how bad the situation was. But
they persevered. And he like I said, you
even said the word seed right now. They
they mentioned the mustard seed. And
from that tiny thing and even though
they went through so much suffering and
sacrifices, it developed. It took
centuries. and and and that's why you
know when we talk about Europe right now
um this even if even if this was
emulated and something like that would
happen a sort of resistance movement
it's going to take a long time to you
know readjust and realign and bring
things back to normal but it could be
done even these guys look what they did
they they chose a life of sacrifice for
what they believe and they actually uh
anchored it in Christian faith um and
they fought back and and and maybe out
of some other point we can talk about
just war theory because that's a whole
other issue. You know, I I if you're
willing, man, I I'd love to have you
back regularly to tell these stories to
bring them back into the forefront of of
our consciousness uh uh here in the
States and and in the Christian
consciousness to reinvigorate Christian
men to recognize what where they come
from and the heritage. I I would love to
have you back. Um Raymond, what what's
going on right now in your life? Uh
where can people find all of your
material? Where what what what where
where can they find your books and how
can they follow you?
Sure, David. Um, the one easy quick way
is just my website, uh, raymond
Ibrahim.com. R A Y M O N G I B R A H I
M. And all my articles are there and
links to my books and videos. I've been
trying to kind of cultivate a YouTube
channel, so on occasion I also make
videos. Um, and this video will will be
on it as well, which is good. And um as
far as the topics that we're discussing
because you know I've read several books
and each one deals with something and I
had it right here because I was actually
quoting from it. But anyone who's
interested in the the heroic aspect uh
here it is defenders of the west the
Christian heroes who stood against
Islam. The story of uh uh Pelagius is in
there that that I was talking about, but
also all these other guys who like I
said who just and so many of them are
and you know like King Richard, you hear
about King Richard and you read what's
written about him by modern historians
and he just appears like a bub, you
know, a dirt bag and he's just like
really bad way. You read the primary
sources including what the Muslims said
about him and you just get this amazing
hero, a self-sacrificing king basically.
So, there's definitely a lot of
correctives that need to be done, but um
yeah, if anyone's interested, I think I
would recommend that book because it
really is no, it's the one that will
most inspire young men, um to understand
what it was to become a Christian
warrior.
Outstanding. Raymond, I can't thank you
enough and and Godspeed on your journey
and your message, brother. Take care.
Thank you, David. I appreciate it.
saying to you.